[Music]
they mourned in Corpus Christi Texas
today Salinas family her friends and her
fans said farewell to the young woman
who meant so much to all of them we
asked that you also will extend such
comfort to the mother and father sister
and brother the husband of Selena men
today's funeral ended a weekend of
mourning for the Tohono superstar more
than 30 thousand people passed by her
casket so overwhelmed by their grief
that they could not speak only week
[Music]
mourning was not confined to her
hometown in Los Angeles at the very
arena where she was to have performed
last Saturday night thousands attended a
mass in her honor
they grieved not just for a star but for
a Roma it's good for like a punch in the
heart to be natural she was a very good
influence to all the kids dancer Alix
Restrepo performed in one of her videos
she said a very positive example
when she was gunned down Friday
allegedly by her fan club president
Selina was one of the biggest stars of
the spanish-language music scene poised
for a breakthrough into mainstream pop
she had already sold millions of records
and won a Grammy thank you thank you
very much
her music had become a staple at
spanish-language radio station Katy and
Q in Los Angeles fans have placed a
memorial outside and disc jockey Amalia
Gonzalez says she will not be forgotten
I have talked to a lot of people and
especially children they think that
Selena was an angel they came they came
to the world to specially to unite all
creeds and races ironically Selena's
tragic death brings her the wide
recognition that she hoped her music
would accomplish despite being only 23
Selena leaves behind a legacy of music
and hope
[Music]
you